a young magician in traditional Bavarian
costume 10 year old max small horror
shows his oktoberfest trick at a
magicians festival far from home in bonn
then we take the second piece of pretzel
and that disappears I'm sure you can
already guess the last piece of pretzel
disappears too I like surprising people
so they go wow how did he do that that's
what's great about magic he came up with
a sketch all by himself
[Music]
up or down it's amazing he's only ten he
didn't make a single mistake and eclipse
the great magicians it was great I'm
sure we'll hear a lot more from him much
goes to school in Dachau near Munich
he's in the fourth grade when he gets
home he spends hours on his hobby magic
muscle that's his stage name has his own
magician's room where he collects props
and tries them out my grandma gave me
this magic kit for my fifth birthday
that's how it all started
magic max allow has his own magician's
case for performances it currently
contains the props for his oktoberfest
act which won him the german junior
magicians competition last year he was
just nine years old and was also
accepted as the youngest member of
Germany's magicians society the Magic
Circle
mock's test out his new equipment like
this sword bucks in his magicians room
his mother acts as his assistant can you
feel anything yet
I hope mums okay so we now have 15
knives in the top the side and back yeah
I'm intrigued to know what it looks like
inside yeah each was a guess from say
his made for the stage he's never shy in
front of the audience and feels
completely at home on stage so I think
he's got what it takes to be a magician
was fine and so Laura the ten-year-old
has hosted shows with up to 800 people
in the audience
[Laughter]
[Music]
his other passion is playing the piano
another hobby that requires nimble
fingers
[Music]
rasam via TV doing magic help strain
your fingers for playing the piano and
vice versa so it works well sounds good
twice a month max meets up with other
magicians from unix magic ring club it's
almost like a family gathering where he
not only has fun but can also learn a
lot it's great to swap ideas and make
friends with people who have the same
hobby as me he gets taken seriously
because of what he dance obviously he's
still a child but the tricks that he
does are very advanced and he's clearly
a natural when it comes to presenting
those tricks to the public if you're
wondering how the ball got from my
pocket to underneath the cup you're
probably wondering how an egg got there
- not to mention the second egg magic
muscle can already compete with many of
the great magicians and he gives
autographs like a pro to
you